do you enjoy parking yourself in front  of a screen then streaming TV shows and  movies until your eyes bleed and you  pass out into snacks well then do we  have a show for you  I'm Lucy and welcome to binge watch  you'll go to for everything to do with  TV movies and any other kind of stream  friendly entertainment  join me Dave anta more every week as we  bring you the latest TV highlights from  hulu amazon netflix and any other moving  picture services will also be dissecting  the biggest blockbuster trailers  discussing the latest news and of course  dishing out our recommendations  so whether you're excited about Marvel's  impending infinity war F Society taking  on evil Corp or just tightens kickin  down walls then this is the place to be  from July eighteenth you can see us here  every monday at youtube.com slash  gamespot or on gamespot com go screen  you